yeah oh god I mean it's just the same I
mean just as environmentally and in
terms of social unrest and eight other
ways they're this close to everything
just kind of the wheels cut it off right
now the central government is
desperately trying to get industry
moving inland because bringing a hundred
million for log perhaps two hundred
million workers on a migrant basis to
the coastal factories is you know it's a
logistical nightmare and a humanitarian
disaster too so there's there's there's
a huge ongoing effort to try to get got
all that industry inland but it may not
happen in time and they're racing
against these impatient western
companies that you know don't want to
raise the cost of you know a lawn chair
set at Walmart if you raise that six
dollars well then they're all going to
go to costco and everybody at costco is
thinking the same thing so no there's no
price flexibility over here so there's
you know all the American buyers are you
know this far away from taking it all to
India or to Vietnam or try again in
South America or something like that I
mean China has huge structural
advantages and it's not good i don't
think the economy is entirely going to
tank but there are i don't know about
Malthusian it's just it doesn't know
great labor situation no great economic
situation lasts forever and there is and
i think probably the first thing to give
will be the environment here more than
anything else and I think the Chinese
government knows that and is hoping you
know if you staple on enough
environmental reform maybe it'll be
enough to get us down the next mile
in Shanghai it will me it will look like
not having any water drink it will look
like they're their source of drinking
water for a city that's already at 20
million and should shoot up to 30
million in any month now that suddenly
what you got coming out of the tap is
salt water salt water filled with
cadmium and mercury from you know 14,000
polluting factories up the Yangtze it's
a real bad problem when you when you run
out of water and they have they have
just disastrous water problems right now
water tables are collapsing everywhere
the climate of course is changing its
changing for the much drier they were
worried about floods just 10 years ago
they did all of this massive you know
social engineering stuff to deal with
the floods now you know it's like it
gets all blow it away the profits and
storms and no water table so water
that's it that's a good one you're
really you're kind of screwed when you
die on the water